[Music]
intense diplomacy ahead of this event
has been going on for years this has
been billed as the conference that can
save the planet
its host the uk prime minister making
the point that the city where it's being
held glasgow was the place where the
steam engine was invented 250 years ago
triggering an industrial revolution that
started the climate crisis
yes my friends we've brought you to the
very place where the doomsday machine
began to tick humanity has long since
run down the clock on climate change
it's one minute to midnight on that
doomsday clock and we need
to act now
and the warnings of what is at stake
here continued this from the un
secretary general our addiction to
fossil fuels
is pushing humanity to the brink
we face a stark choice
either we stop it
or it stops us
we are digging our own graves
us president joe biden came to glasgow
with unlike his predecessor donald trump
a strong commitment to fight the climate
emergency but without the tools to do so
his green policies depend on a massive
spending package that has already been
paired back and has yet to pass congress
there's no more time to hang back or sit
in the fence or argue amongst ourselves
this is the challenge of our collective
lifetimes
the existential threat threat to human
existence as we know it
the president told delegates the eyes of
history were on them but president
biden's own eyes were the subject of
speculation on social media did he doze
off at one point as he listened to the
speeches
here in glasgow there'll be 12 days of
long intense negotiations for this vital
conference to be a success all the stars
need to align but some powerful leaders
like president xi of china and russia's
president putin are not here and there's
not been the hope for momentum ahead of
cop 26.
over the weekend in rome the leaders of
the most prosperous nations on the
planet met they said all the right words
about the climate but they didn't take
the action that was needed according to
environmentalists
living on the front line mia motley is
the prime minister of barbados a small
island nation that was battered by a
hurricane in july cold red
cold red
to the g7 countries
code red
code red to the g20
earth the cop
that's what it said
earth to cop
for those who have ice to see for those
who have ears to listen
and for those who have a heart to feel
1.5 is what we need to survive the
urgency of the situation is obvious but
it's still not clear there's the
commitment by all nations to try to fix
things
james bays al jazeera glasgow
well our environment editor nick clark
continues our cop 26 coverage live from
glasgow nick
hello yeah thanks very much lots of bold
impassioned speeches on day two of the
u.n climate conference here in glasgow
but then
u.n prime minister narendra modi
came to the stage came to the podium and
just before we go to a clip of his
remember that a key target here is to
get all the countries to agree that net
zero should happen by 2050.
he really
changed direction on that and said that
he's going for 2017.
india will fulfill 50 of its energy
requirements from renewable energy
sources by 2030 between now and 2030
india will reduce its total projected
carbon emissions by 1 billion tons by
2030 india will reduce the carbon
intensity of its economy by 45
and by 2070 india will achieve the
target of net zero emissions
well let's explore this further take
this on we can speak to uh peter betts
uh he's an associate fellow in the
energy and environment resources program
at chatham house and you were also a
former lead negotiator with the eu in
the uk so you know exactly what's what
at these climate conferences so first up
the indian pm just going for net zero by
2070. they hadn't actually come up with
any pledge to for carbon neutral at any
point but now they have but it's 2070
which is 20 years two decades after the
target here which is 2050.
uh thanks nick my immediate reaction is
actually this is a very positive step by
mr modi you know i think if you'd if you
if you look back a couple of years ago
we only had about a quarter of the
world's emissions covered by net zero
targets we've now got 85 percent of the
world's emissions covered by net zero
targets this is this is a an absolutely
unmistakable signal the direction that
the world's economy is moving
but
to achieve or to keep one and a half
degrees celsius uh in touch
what's it going to do to that is it is
it going to scupper the chances of that
happening at this conference
not at all i mean i think i think when
we talk about keeping 1.5 alive we're
not suggesting we're going to solve
everything in this meeting
so you know i personally attach more
importance to the to the 2030 targets
the targets that countries have to set
for 2030
actually we've got significant progress
there but nothing like enough
we're going to leave this meeting having
made progress but we are not fully on
track for 1.5 so when we talk about
keeping 1.5 alive we mean we make as
much progress as we can can
and then we come back for more and we
and we double down on what we've already
achieved
modi also went on to talk about climate
finance and demanding 11 trillion
dollars to be made available uh for
developing nations it's not realistic is
it
uh no i don't think it is realistic
short term i think that um
you know clearly developed countries
have to deliver on their commitment to
mobilize 100 billion a year and it's
regrettable that they did that late
and i know there's discussion about
whether it should be met on average over
the period up to 2025 but when you talk
about these much bigger numbers clearly
you know all these emerging economies
are going to be investing trillions
anyway developing their economies and
growing building their infrastructure
the
the objective is to shift that
infrastructure investment which is
happening anyway and make it low carbon
and climate resilient and increasingly
we're seeing it needn't cost more in
fact it even costs less in many
instances renewable energy for example
now much cheaper
than coal in most parts of the world
we've had no new commitments no further
embroidering of china's position
how much of an issue is that
i think that's that's that for me is a
much bigger issue and is frankly
disappointing
um you know i was quite pleased with the
leadership that president xi showed back
in september of last year when he
announced
a net zero goal for china for 2060
but i really was hoping as many many
other observers were for a significant
tightening of china's target for 2030
and we've seen very little and i find
that a disappointing lack of leadership
from china
johnson biden david attenborough are all
evoking future generations they're the
ones that most at risk here what is the
the best the extensive youth movement
the youth activists that we're seeing
here
can expect from this conference directly
i think you know a lot of a lot of what
this conference needs
needs to deliver was done as we came in
before we got here we've got you know
commitments from most of the big
developed economies except australia i'm
afraid to say to pretty well halve their
emissions by 2030. that's a step forward
we're now seeing some of the big
emerging economies make ambitious
commitments that's great as well but
it's clear that we don't have remotely
enough yet
to put us on track so we need to bank
what we've got
uh i think we've got some quite exciting
sector announcements coming in the
course of the next week or so on you
know
reducing deforestation
committing to phase out internal
combustion engines
phasing out fossil fuel
financing
reducing methane emissions i think these
can build on those ndcs but i do think
at the end of this cop
there's going to have to be a
conversation
which many of the vulnerable countries
are pushing for already about a much
earlier return to the table than 2025 i
think next year or the year after we're
going to have to invite countries
particularly those who haven't stepped
up to the plate to
consider whether they might be prepared
to do some more all right lots of
negotiating and battling ahead
peterborough appreciate that thanks very
much thank you thank you
all right let's move on to the the best
and the worst when it comes to emissions
starting off with china we've just been
talking about china they pump more than
14 billion tons of carbon dioxide
methane and other gases into the
atmosphere each year that's more than
all developing countries combined
overall china accounts for around 27
of global emissions followed by the us
india the eu and indonesia although the
united states and europe have been the
worst polluters
historically
on the other end are bhutan and suriname
and they say they've managed to become
carbon negative
well now we're going to liberia to
monroeville liberia has struggled to
deal with environmental challenges the
2020 environmental performance index in
fact ranked at the worst performing
country when it comes to sustainability